hey everyone today I want to talk about
how do you create a product or service
that people will pay you for so in my
mastermind group one of my members this
morning that's the question she's a
writer and she's trying to figure out
from the other people in the group what
kind of writing services do you need
would you ever hire not that she's
trying to sell herself just trying to
figure out where the demand is what the
people need you need blog post and you
need social media posting help do you
need landing page copy you need ghost
read what do you need in your business
so she just has an understanding of the
market and so my answer today will help
her but also help anybody who is trying
to figure out how do you create a
product or service that people will pay
you money for and I've got three tips
that I want to share today so the first
is remember that the amount of money
that you make will depend on the value
that you're providing and it's not so
much the actual value often it's more
the perceived value what do people
actually think the value is that you're
providing and the bigger the pain is the
easier it is to get a yes and the more
immediate you're gonna get that yes the
faster they're gonna write that check to
you because they perceive this huge pain
if they don't feel like it's a big pain
or big need it's gonna be a lot harder
to then try to convince them that they
could use your services and often I find
way better to move on and so you may
find a lot of people saying hey I need
social media help or hey I need blog
posting help or any I need you to help
them with this ghost writing project but
do they really need it desperately
that's where you're gonna get people
making fast decisions and paying you a
lot of money so you know maybe only one
in a hundred people are writing back and
saying yah I need help writing blog post
so maybe that one person is working at a
company and is about to get fired if he
doesn't improve the performance of his
blog and he's gonna have you come in and
help him right like that's that's a
pretty big situation and one where
you're gonna get a quick yes make lots
of money with it and so always remember
that the money you make is gonna come
from the perceived value from the pain
that they're feeling
number two is any
closer to the sale is also gonna result
in a faster yes and more dollars it's a
little bit sad but people are very
short-sighted and they want to see
immediate results and something like
landing page copy if the company has
invest in a landing page right they've
invested in that marketing strategy not
convincing them they need landing pages
they've already gone down that path and
they have a landing page and it's
performing maybe underperform and they
want to try to optimize it and you come
in and help on the copy that is easy for
somebody to understand how do I
translate content into money right I'm
selling whatever product I have I'm
selling my shoe right and by you coming
in and testing that copy I can quickly
figure out if you're making me more
money or not right it's something that
brands and companies and entrepreneurs
will place a more immediate dollar value
on and say yes quickly because they've
already seen results with a landing page
and you're really close to a sale where
the further away you are from the sales
process the harder it is to get a yes so
for example social media you know social
media is a lot newer not many companies
are making lots of money yet on social
media it's more of a branding exercise
of customer service customer relations
get to know your audience
build an audience where it's not south
south south south south where the point
of a landing page is to sell and so
because you're further removed from the
sales process it's a lot harder to sell
social media copy than landing page copy
right and again it's a little sad
because it's important like writing good
posts on social media is super important
there's some comes that do it well most
businesses don't and they just don't
value it and so you could be out
pitching it to them it could be falling
on deaf ears because they don't see how
it's gonna generate more money for them
and they can't see that clearly then
it's hard for you to sell that to them
and change their mindset and again
better move on to somebody else so again
closer you are to the sale the easier it
is to get a yes and the more money
you're gonna make the third point is
this is the curveball I almost don't
care about points of Lenin - the reason
is I would focus I would go all in on
what I'm great at right I would do
thinking about what you excel I think
about the type of cop you love writing
the types of clients that you love
working with and go all in on that
because the market is huge right there's
tons of writers there for those times of
competition for you but the demand the
market for writing is also huge right
ginormous lots of people need writing
and so the challenge is if you don't
stand out from everybody else you're
gonna be lumped into oh this is just
another writer and you're gonna get
beaten down on your price point where
what you want to do is be the clear
choice for a certain group of customers
and everybody else can ignore you laugh
at you whatever they're not interested
in you that's great you want them to
self-identify that they're not a
potential client so it's getting dead
simple clear on the types of people we
want to work with and the types of
projects that you want to work on and be
the expert of that so an example that I
shared in the recent video I guess not
even recent there a long time ago that
that somebody brought up recently was a
photographer if you're a photographer
that's great but this tons of
photographers so combine your passions
and if you are productive or that loves
bowling for example you could be the
number one bowling photographer there's
a market for that people who want the
best bowling pictures and because you
understand how bowlers work and your
bowling fan yourself you're gonna take
amazing pictures it's combining your
passions now somebody who wants a
corporate headshot is gonna find that I
don't want to work with this guy because
he's a bowler right he takes bowling
shots what does he know about corporate
headshots and that's fantastic because
the CEO corporate headshot guy is not
going to be an ideal fit client for you
anyway
so instead of trying to be everything to
all people segmented down so if you're
looking at writing who are the types of
people that you want to work with and
then go all-in on those people have a
appeal to them that is makes immediate
sense where if I hate your website if I
look into social media if I look
your videos I'm immediately drawn to
your message or not like I self
eliminate super quick and you're not
going to be my pile of writers and what
it does is allow you to stand out
separate yourself charge a higher price
and you get to work with more ideal
clients have more fun get more referrals
feel more satisfaction because the
progress that you're working on are
having an impact and you're working with
clients if you'd like I'm going on a bit
of a rant there but yeah I think you
should go all in on that and makes sense
logically the first two points but focus
on where you excel focus on what you
love and you're gonna see much better
results believe thanks to the question